automatic facial expression recognition
is the ability of a machine usually a
computer to automatically recognize
expressions of emotion or expressions of
social signals basically facial displays
that we make smiling by a computer so
it's inherently a computer vision
problem it's inherently a problem of
turning pixels from the that are
captured by camera into symbols such as
this person is smiling this person is
blinking this person is nodding their
head that's what facial expression
recognition is all about
you can speak of a general pipeline a
general processing pipeline of problems
that you need to solve in order to get
to that final smile detection you can
find now in most consumer cameras
actually so the first problem they need
to solve is you need to know where the
face is of course if the face is not
found at all then you don't even know
what you're processing right so you have
to start by locating the face that's
done with a process called face
detection funnily enough and once you
have found that there might be a problem
that people's faces have different
shapes you may have found a very big
shape face you may found a very small
face the face may have been tilted so
you need to go through a process called
face alignment or face registration
that's at which you sort of remove
differences between subjects between
different people such as identity or the
size of somebody's face in general and
you can remove variations that are
caused within that subject because they
move their heads or they they its most
important a hot pose actually and the
way we do that generally is by first
finding a number of points on the face
and now we basically divide the points
on the face in two types one is types of
ones points that do move when you
express her like my mouth cornice when I
smile they will go up and out
and then there's also facial points that
do not move when you when you express or
barely so that's the your inner eye
corners your outer eye corners your nose
I mean if you look very carefully and I
flare my nostrils you could you could
see the move but I generally don't and
so you've got stable points those are
your inner eye corners your outer eye
corners the points around your nose and
if you use those you can remove any
rotations any scaling and positioning of
course of the face once you're done with
that then come sort of the the real
interesting computer vision problems and
that is feature extraction so imagine
you've got a 200 by 200 pixel area
around the face each of those pixels can
have 256 different values if we're just
talking about gray skill so that's not
even taking color into account that
means you have a very large search space
a very large space of possible values
within that image and it's too high so
classical machine learning so this is
the part that will automatically learn
whether it's a smile or not cannot deal
with such an immense search space so we
need to lower that so there's two things
you can do you first feel you want to
lower that amount of variability and
also you want to only capture variations
that are caused by expressions and you
want to do away with any variation
that's caused by for example identity or
illumination variation right so there's
all kinds of different techniques
basically you can you can split them
into two groups one of them is based on
geometric features and geometric
features are features that are
calculated from facial points remember
we have the facial points the stable
points on the nose and the eyes that did
not move with expression but the other
ones they do move with expression so my
mouth corners over expression and Fuchs
but if you wanted to know whether I was
smiling you would just look at these two
points and if they go out and up
relatively to all the other facial
points you can say that I'm smiling with
some degree of certainty and so that's a
geometric fish point and you can also
look at appearance appearance basically
means the type of wrinkles we have it's
also includes color so you can if I
frown you get all kinds of wrinkles here
that's the kind of thing you want to
capture but also you could use
appearance to look at the edges that are
caused by my eyebrows compared to my
skin or my forehead so those are the two
general approach that you do and of
course if you if you're doing it right
you're going to use both and that way
you can get a very stable system I can
smile lab I don't necessarily mean that
I'm smiling so that's a different kind
of yes so if you question maybe well
it's that is a different question but
you couldn't we've done research into
automatically distinguishing fake from
real smiles or posts from spontaneous
smiles and you can do that based on the
temporal dynamics in smiles actually you
can do it both on temporal dynamics
that's the activation pattern a fake
smile is quick smooth and short so you
get a quick upward trajectory I keep it
there a little bit and then it goes back
to a real smile has multiple intensity
levels multiple Peaks it is slower in
onset it's story and offset that's one
telltale difference the other telltale
difference is which is called a Duchenne
smile so you've got the orbicularis
oculi muscle that's around the eye and
when that contracts especially the outer
ring when that contracts it pulls up the
cheek and it creates the the crowd feeds
at the at the eye corner it's more
apparent with people who can live older
and that muscle
that's it's called action at 6:00 in the
facial action coding system is something
that is normally not shown when people
do a polite smile or a post smile or
fake smile although you can you can
teach somebody to do that so if you want
to become a good expert at pretending to
be happy or you can learn how to do that
it's harder to to to to learn yourself
to do the temple dynamics that's
probably almost impossible
you